behind the door of a me Shapiro's lab a
menagerie of robots
there's the snake it can be used for a
certain rescue to go underneath the
collapsed building and look for a
survivor the tumble BOTS like two means
of the snake robot you can move around
it can even climb the a small sir and
this one that looks like an extra from
Star Wars we for research on the walking
robot on developing algorithms for a
four-legged robot to walk safely in
rough terrain and very uneven terrain
like boulders like the edge of perfectly
this one here it's quite scary but one
of these ones do these are wall climbing
robots they they are using magnets to
climb on metal surfaces they're used for
inspection of the heart of the ship to
see if there is no bomb board rod
attached and to replace the diagonal
many of the boats being built here are
funded by and destined for Israel's
military
some are more impressive than others
perhaps my favorite robot from Amyas lab
snakey notwithstanding is this it's an
all-terrain Butler bot it recognizes me
using an Xbox Kinect sensor and then it
will follow me wherever I go you can use
it to carry items it's carrying my
notepad right now it can be used in the
military for example to carry equipment
alas Amyas prototypes aren't for sale
and even though some are made of Lego
and use remote controls they're most
definitely not toys and yet got can
Bloomberg bear Sheva southern Israel